ми належали до категорії особливу
небезпечних державних злочинців
убивці такими до такої категорії не
відносяться Я і Мої колеги відчули
трупний запах Російської імперії
розпад Радянського Союзу поставив росіян
перед вибором так що ви вважаєте
головним етичний
аспект чи територіальний в Росія немає
жодних скульпулів душевних вона буде
робити все для того щоб знищити Україну
сьогодні ми поговоримо з українським
дисидентом політв'язнем часів СРСР
членом співзасновником Української
Гельсінської групи та проректором
українського католицького університету
Мирослава мариновичем пане Мирослава
хотіла би почати з питання Українська
Гельсінська група потім Українська
Гельсінська спілка були засновані ще за
роки до проголошення незалежності
України і до проголошення Конституції
України а от саме в Гельсінських угодах
були ті основні положення багато з яких
є в Конституції України сучасній як на
вашу думку діяльність членів Української
Гельсінської групи вплинула на
встановлення незалежності України і
повпливала можливо і на
початки формування Конституції України
Ну я би сказав так що в час Гельсінських
угод
Україна входила
в сферу тоталітарних держав вона
перебувала в складі тоталітарної держави
і
мови про демократію взагалі не йшло
звичайно ж в Радянському Союзі багато
говорили про те що
Радянська система
найдемократичніша в світі Але зрозуміло
що це був ідеологічний фейк а насправді
Це була тоталітарна держава і в особі
гельсінської групи
Україна Я би сказав зробила дуже важливу
спробу увійти в цивілізацію прав людини
увійти в цивілізацію європейську яка є
демократичною за суттю
на той час це була ну така дуже рішуча
ледь не божевільна спроба тому що вона
вимагала жертв від людей але
попри те
значення того що українці
ціною жертв виявили бажання бути
у тій цивілізації прав людини ну
значення цього є дуже великим
країна остання з колишніх радянських
республік яка якраз проголосила свою
Конституцію і майже 5 років Незалежності
користувалася ще тією конституцією УРСР
Як ви думаєте чому так склалося
Україна
мала дуже складне громадянське
суспільство на початку
тому що
дуже великий процент був
тих людей які так ще інакше
призвичаїлася до радянської влади до
радянських реалій і вже не виявляли
прагнення змінити
їх
іншими словами були
була значна частина суспільства яка
звиклася до Радянського комуністичного
рабства
і тому
шлях до звільнення
мусить бути довший
[музика]
знаєте легко
скинути
пам'ятник Леніну
Значно важче скинути сліди по
комуністичної системи з умів людських І
от це вимагало більшого часу
і за свою діяльність
дисидентську в відсиділи 7 років
ув'язнення і 5 років таборів заслання
так виходить 7 років ув'язнення в
таборах суворого режиму і три роки
заслання у Казахстані в мене за вироком
суду було 12 років тобто 7 років
ув'язнення і 5 років заслання але
Горбачов у
87-му році
помилував десь приблизно 200
політв'язнів в тім числі і мене тому на
два роки було скорочено
ну розпочну жарту
під час слідства я зауважив що
наша правозахисна діяльність трактується
значно гостріше
ніж скажімо діяльність вбивць
ми належали до категорії особливо
небезпечних державних злочинців
убивці такими до такої категорії не
відносяться і коли я іронічно зауважив
про це
то мій слідчий сказав так Ви маєте рацію
тому що убивця вбиває одну людину Там
максимум двох
ви ж заражаєте своїми ідеями масою людей
і тому ви для суспільства є
небезпечнішим
Отже Радянська система трималася на
страхові і на брехні
Дисиденти усі але члени Гельсінської
групи зокрема
цілили власне в оті дві опори радянської
влади по-перше своїм публічним виступом
ми показували що радянську владу можна
не боятися А друге ми не боялися
говорити що король голий ми не боялися
говорити що система збудована на брехні
і про цю брехню свідчить
А як себе в той час поводили
Дисиденти інших таких груп в інших
соціалістичних республіках наприклад
члени Московської Гельсінської групи чи
вони теж боролися які вибрати того
режиму
без сумніву
і я би дуже не хотів применшувати
значення оцього оцієї етичної постави
російських дисидентів багато в чому в
той час вони були для нас зразками
була про те одна важлива відмінність у
поставі національних дисидентів і
московських так би мовити
вони виступали виключно за
демократизацію Радянського Союзу
національні Дисиденти Виступали не
тільки за демократизацію Радянського
Союзу але із-за припинення імперії за
звільнення своїх народів
що для московських дисидентів було часом
не зрозуміло часом шкідливо для
демократичної мети
і вони не завжди були в тими власне
нотками визвольними у наших позиціях в
Росії якраз заборонили Московську
діяльність Московської гайсинської групи
В грудні Минулого року як ви це оцінюєте
що ви про це думаєте Ну ми в Росії
заборонили також і діяльність меморіалу
що для мене навіть є більшим ударом тому
що
привозахисні групи оцінюють сучасність а
меморіал оцінював минуле
І в чому була його унікальна роль
оцінити минуле тоталітарне минуле Росії
без
аналізу того минулого неможливо говорити
про майбутнє Росії про успішне майбутнє
Росії і теж той факт що меморіал закрили
засвідчує що
Путін і його режим
не хочуть
переосмислити скажімо сталінський період
комуністичний період взагалі що Це для
них є
просто різні форми одного і того самого
славного імперського минулого Росії Якщо
порівнювати два режими теперішній
путінський і той при якому ви
відсиділили стільки років ув'язнення Як
ви можете їх порівняти і так само крім
самого режиму і свободу слова взагалі
права людини порівняти Ці дві системи є
велика різниця між сталінським періодом
і періодом Брежнєв скажімо у сталінський
період - це було Це було було брутальне
насильство
абсолютно різних форм
брежнєвський період - Це
був період коли
все це насильство пробували
прилакувати
коли не було такого скажімо
впродовж брежнєвського періоду Я
особисто в булаву не зазнав фізичного
насильства
були різні форми голод холод
психологічне знущання але не було
фізичного насильства тоді як в
сталінській період його було дуже багато
і якщо тепер взяти путінський режим
путінський період я би міг сказати що
знову взято за модель сталінського
взято за приклад сталінського модель і в
цьому є
[музика]
страхітливий злочин
путінського режиму бо він не тільки не
переосмислив злочини минулого а навпаки
ті злочини проросли новим
таким
новими злочинами сьогодні
чи вірите ви в демократизацію Росії що
вона можливо
перша відповідь така пряма відповідь ні
І я завжди
критично ставився до всіх тих наївних
уявлень на заході що ось прийде новий
генеральний секретар тепер Президент
Росії і все і країна за 5-10 років стане
демократичною ні такого не станеться
про те на відміну від масового уявлення
в Україні про те що це ніколи не
станеться я все-таки вважаю що Господь
не створив злочинних народів
народи можуть бути злочинними
в певний період своєї свого життя так
скажімо
німці
у 43-му 41-му
45-39
роках це був Злочинний народ безсумнівно
але цей народ зумів переосмислити Своє
минуле і зумів стати нормальним
європейським народом тому я її повторюю
що я залишаю якусь так би мовити
шпарку для того щоби все-таки можна було
переосмислити Своє минуле і
вірю в те що власне оскільки Господь не
створив
злочинних народів то він
зарезервував який шлях для цього народу
до повного е доповненої трансформації
але я припускаю що в такому випадку це
буде не Російська імперія а
національна держава російського народу
тобто те що чого поки що немає
Російська імперія ніколи не зміниться
Вона завжди буде такою якою в нас є
зараз Як ви думаєте чому тоді за
радянських часів коли не було інтернету
протестний рух правозахисний рух був
більшим ніж зараз наприклад проти
Вторгнення в чехословаччину чи проти
війни в Афганістані А зараз ми такого не
бачимо
цікаве питання Я не знаю на нього
відповіді і можу сказати що
це самого мене тривожить тому що
історію етичний і потенціал російського
дисидентства був в якомусь сенсі для нас
зразком
сахару був для нас зразком він обстоював
він захищав життя українських дисидентів
тому українські Дисиденти скажімо
виступили недавно проти ідеї того щоби
вулиці Сахарова в наших українських
містах були перейменовані Ні ми вважаємо
що сахаром
має величезні заслуги перед українським
народом чому цей етичний потенціал
сьогодні зник
це цікаве питання і я припускаю що
головною причиною
розгубленості росіян і
їхньої тривоги є те що
російська ідея завжди була пов'язана з
територією з примноженням території
ми великая страна и великая страна не в
сенсі там якихось духовних цих А перед
усім територія і Росії має бути багато
розпад Радянського Союзу
поставив росіян перед вибором так що ви
вважаєте головним етичний
аспект чи
територіальний і поки що росіяни в
розгубленості вони би хотіли зберегти
велич географічну своєї імперії і при
цьому хотіли би тим Я маю на увазі
ліберальні росіяни і хотіли би стати
[музика]
демократичною країною
цього зробити не вдасться чи є для вас
зараз хороші росіяни є я з ними сидів ні
скажи моя не можу забути
ім'я і постать мого
табірного побратима росіянина Владимира
балахонова
які під впливом українців Він дуже
потягнувся до нас і під впливом
українців він цілковито змінив свою
поставу він усвідомив небезпеку
Російської імперії мало того що він сам
усвідомив він
78-го року
написав дуже важливу статтю в якій він
звернувся до заходу з такою апеляцією
врахуйте що Російська імперія буде
небезпечною завжди
вона обов'язково доведе свій до якоїсь
великої кризи що світ має зробити це має
дезінтегрувати розчленувати Російську
імперію і залишити для росіян тільки
історичні землі довкола Москви на яких
вони сформувалися
Скажіть будь ласка що я маю
вважати поганого в його поставі Я вважаю
що він зробив
величезний крок в осмисленні свого і
повторюю що це 78-й рік це не 2023
А як ви оцінюєте такі практики коли
наприклад Нобелівську премію Миру дали
Україні російські Федерації Білорусі Я
тут вбачаю
інерцію
тої російської пропагандистської течії
яка
трансформувала західну освіту
і усіх західних університетах всі вчили
про те що
[музика]
Русь єдина колиска трьох братніх народів
і що головні там росіяни скажімо
Гантінгтон переконував у своїй праці що
нації ядром Східної Європи є російський
народ
і
так така візія була в усіх підручниках у
всіх лекціях університетських на заході
відповідно
ці люди не можуть оцінювати інакше вони
вони бояться виокремити одну націю
скажімо українську а як же ж так це не
політкоректно тоді обра є дві інші треба
їх обов'язково разом називати так і і
все це мене нам треба буде багато
попрацювати на заході
зараз на повному серйозі вже ведеться
розмова про
деколонізацію
освіти на заході це дуже важливе поняття
де колонізація західної освіти і тому
шанс на те що все зміниться є Як ви
думаєте що буде далі з УПЦ МП і щоб мало
бути з ними далі
Я дуже добре запам'ятав собі першу
лекцію
в колумбійському університеті США на
курсах права людини релігійна свобода
і там ще щось я вже забувся як воно там
називалося
на першій лекції було сказано так
Так звичайно є
випадки коли
священики духовенство якоїсь церкви
порушує державне законодавство Але для
того щоб їх покарати не потрібно
забороняти всю релігійну організацію
потрібно
використовувати державні закони для того
щоб
бути покарати за конкретні порушення
ось це є логіка сучасного розуміння прав
людини держава має право
відстежувати поведінку своїх громадян і
якщо громадяни займаються як в нашому
випадку
колабораціонізмом з ворогом якщо
передають інформацію і воєнного
характеру таємного характеру і так далі
то то це підлягає звичайному
законодавству і треба судити не можна
уникати засудження
духовенства тільки тому що воно
духовенство вони є громадяни України і
вони на них розповсюджуються закон
Україна довший час цього не робила
і відповідно
коли слухаєш сьогоднішніх керівників
Московського Патріархату в Україні то
просто вражаєшся як
будь-яке домагання з
справедливого застосування закону
викликає у них єдину реакцію гоніння на
церкву
це є абсолютно неприйнятно Вони мають
підлягати закону це але це є лише одна
правда бо як правозахисник ви проти
повної заборони друга частина Правди це
те що
релігійна свобода є однією з базових
свобод в умовах демократії якщо ми
перекреслимо релігійну свободу До речі
релігійна свобода є надзвичайно важливим
завоюванням української демократії Ми
звикли до релігійної Свободи вона в для
нас є органічною це прекрасно Я вважаю
що Це величезне досягнення тридцятиліття
української незалежності і тому якщо ми
зараз перекреслимо це
Ну ми
вийде так щоби боремося за демократію ми
вважаємо себе першим таким головним
фронтом сьогодні боротьби за демократію
а будемо самі в собі цю демократію
губити тому ось
теорія прав людини дає прекрасний
розв'язок для цього карати порушників
законодавства і захищати релігійні права
людей які не порушили законодавство А що
ви думаєте на рахунок питання мови яке
час від часу підіймається
Я дуже боюся цих розмов
Я би сказав так
припиніть про це говорити сьогодні
я
не маю морального права
сказати російськомовному українцеві який
сьогодні Мене захищає В окопах що він не
має права говорити російською мовою я не
маю морального права поставити під
сумнів його патріотизму українській
тому
не маючи такого морального права Я
вважаю що ми не маємо піднімати цю тему
сьогодні
при чому я розумію що проблема мови є
важливою для України Ми дуже тяжко
переживали цю проблему раніше на ній
дуже добре спекулювали політики дуже
успішно спекулювали
і
українізація так ще інакше відбудеться
вона вже відбувається але просто
усвідомо що ця проблема потребує
більшого часу її не можна зробити від
однієї команди від будь-кого одніє одна
команда і через місяць проблему знято
Такого не буває ви вже бачили розпад
Радянського Союзу Можливо ви тоді
відчували якісь передумови як на вашу
думку
зараз складеться після перемоги України
звичайно доля Росії і доля України
я ще в березні і десь приблизно в
березні
22-го року сформулював в одній своїй
статті таку тезу що
в брежнєвський час
в 70-х роках коли я перебував в таборах
Я і мої побратими виразно чули трупний
запах Радянського Союзу
хоча режим був дуже потужний ми це
відчували на своїй шкірі але при цьому
ми чули цей трупний запах ми не знали
коли він розпадеться Але в тому що він
розпадеться ми були цілковиті переконані
сьогодні відколи почалося оця масова
Атака проти України масове війна
я можу сказати що відразу
Я і Мої колеги відчули трупний запах
Російської імперії
і
десь навіть ми дуже добре усвідомили
значення того Що робив Путін він просто
усвідомив що треба йти ба-банк Що ще
трошки України відійде назавжди це
остання можливо мить коли ще можна її
захопити Так йому здавалось
і тому він пішов в а-банк
проте
вже тоді ми розуміли що вона заклинеться
Україною і вона захлинається в Україною
так Росія може поставити світ на Грань
такої цілковитої третьої світової війни
цілковито руй третьої світової війни і
справді така небезпека є
Каховка
засвідчила нам що Росія не має жодних
скульпулів душевних вона буде робити все
для того щоб знищити Україну Отже світ
має це розуміти з іншого боку
догоджання агресору не зупинить третю
світову війну а навпаки її наближає
тому Дай Боже щоби захід усвідомив що
оце задобрювання агресора ніколи добром
не
закінчувалось Дякую вам пане Мирослава
за розмову